[Music]
everyone gonna find out about all might
now cuz they're gonna have to see him
when he's like skinny and scrawny now I
only comes to work three hours a day I
imagine they would have to see him like
what about his clothes are they gonna
expand what if you like is super buff
and then I was lunch break he goes back
to being skinny like a Hulk situation
we're like how are his clothes so long
I'm wondering that myself
gotta acknowledge these things you have
to yeah well if I did a Hulk movie it
would be all based around the clothing
business this is hope trying to get his
pants right really self-conscious and
he's like when I shrink back down I
don't want to be naked again or or I'm
gonna do the realistic version of the
Hulk where's all his clothes rip off
he's got giant hole - a giant hole it's
very distracting is every action scene
is this his penises flop down smash
that's how he wins fights though as he
shows up if people like and everybody
uncomfortable with public nudity it's
perfect unhappy happy byproduct of folks
it's circumstances all my might
encounter the same problem this girl
romances building well man and they keep
looking out for each other I've always
said that if you want to get a girl to
like you you put her in danger and then
you rescue her I mean like she doesn't
know you set it up you rescue her she'll
forever idolized you and then if you
were like a terrible boyfriend she'll go
I can't leave him though he saved me so
now you got this like codependent
relationship going on and that's the way
to make love last that's my next
superhero movie is captain codependent
like it starts off where the hero
rescues her then it cuts to like five
years later Jesus really wants out but
you can leave it's like if super
it's my Darren Aronofsky Superman movie
if Superman became an abusive husband it
would certainly be new and fresh for the
genre leave it be if you're gonna do
dark Superman you gotta go all out and
yeah yeah it's just like they did with
dark spider-man not a lot of power
you can't keep you prisoner I have to
see the counselor here look at Lois
Jimmy it's a nice camera would be shame
if something were to happen
oh they gotta make that Superman movie
or at least a five-minute sketch where
Perry White's really a creepy guy but
then you did the counter opposite with a
really bright Batman story yeah yeah
he's got like a really great rapport and
communication ended with Alfred you know
pretty chipper about his work out in the
city loves being Bruce Wayne in fact
that's the main convoy he's having too
much fun being Bruce Wayne to really
fight crime effectively Robins going
through a tough time he's like open up
take a break from training today from
with the Clayface can wait he's always
gonna be around we don't kill even when
we put him in Arkham Asylum which is
good and Batmobile let's talk and safe
in there get some ice cream safe
environment I just want you to feel your
best anyway my hero academia is a fun
show guys